we're now in June 2018 so it's time for
another monthly update video in which
I'll talk about what went on in the
month of May and what we have got coming
up this month of June I always like to
begin by highlighting three big things
and with no further ado here they are
big thing number one I have started a
podcast taking my videos and turning
them into podcast episodes so I'll talk
more about that in the June section big
thing number two also something I'll
talk more about in the June section I
have a Hagel talk coming up very very
soon on the fourth and it's it's being
hosted by the Turtle Island research
cooperative they asked me to do a
introduction to the reading of Hagel so
I'll be doing that and big thing number
three something that happened in May
that you might have missed I provided
both a blog post and then a video
interview for common sense ethics
talking about how to get started in
studying philosophy what went on this
month of May we had quite a few events
one of which started the month a talk in
the Philosopher's in the midst of
history series this one was on Augustine
of Hippo the video for it is linked to
below then following up on that we had
our 50,000 subscribers online party
raised a toast to getting 50 thousand
subscribers on YouTube passing up that
milestone a little bit later in the
month we had another face to face talk
in the worlds of speculative fiction
series this one was on Andre Norton's
witch world then I had a series of
online events the AMA session I did my
philosophy chat from my patreon
supporters of course we had our
philosophy pop-ups this month we
discussed the topic of triggering and
then we finished up
a month with a session of the MKE stoic
fellowship in which we finished up our
study of Senecas letters I also got
ready to begin the podcast that I'm
going to tell you a little bit more
about that in the June sections but
there's a lot of groundwork then I was
laying in May as I mentioned in the
three big things I also did a guest blog
post and then we followed that up with a
interview with my good friend and
colleague Lea goldrich on her blog
common sense ethics and now her video
channel I was discussing the ten works
that I think are perhaps some of the
best to start out studying philosophy
with for a complete beginner so I'll
link to that below as well did a good
bit of writing in our exes do you know
@tk a bit in half our Hegel I also wrote
one piece in policy of truth my friend
and colleague earphones blog and this
month I did a lot of tutorial work a
good bit of consulting work particularly
in the field of ethics and also some
philosophical counseling as well so if
you're interested in that sort of thing
you can always go to the reason IO site
I'll put a link to it below and you can
you can check out the sort of work that
I do video work what videos did we do in
this month of May I released five rather
than the six that I usually do half-hour
Haegele videos I got a little bit behind
in part because of doing the work on the
podcast and a number of other things as
well I released several Heidegger core
concept videos I also produced but
haven't released except from my patreon
supporters a number of videos on Plato's
Republic book 10 which has to do with
mimetic reproduction you may find those
interesting those will be coming out
this this coming month I released a
few more of the Q&A videos I also did a
video about the selfie app the Google
Play thing or the Google arts and
culture thing that you may have seen and
of course we did videos of the events
the other thing that I'll mention that
was really fun this month was my kids
came up for Memorial Day weekend and
that was a lot of fun we I didn't get
any work done of course but we had to
you know we were relaxed a lot we went
to the pool I you know got to hang out
with them and and we did a lot of fun
activities including playing some board
games so that was a really great time
towards the the middle to end part of
the month what have we got coming up in
June so let's start with events first on
the fourth which is tomorrow I'm
recording this on the 3rd right now at
7:30 p.m. Central Standard Time I've
been asked to provide an online session
for a summer seminar on Hegel's
phenomenology and mine is titled
ambitiously enough introduction to the
reading of Hegel this is for the Turtle
Island research cooperative you can see
a link to the event below if you want to
get yourself in on that as far as like
the logistics of that you have to ask
them about the Google hangout which is
how they're going to be doing it rather
than directly asking me then the next
thing that I've got is coming up on the
14th at 7:00 p.m. that's the next
session in our worlds of speculative
fiction series and this time we're
looking at just a giant of science
fiction Arthur Clark will be talking
about some of his novels particularly
rendezvous with Rama childhoods and all
the ones that have to do essentially
with you know the human relation with
with the alien and Beyond on the 19th at
5 p.m. I'll be having
a Hegel a public Hegel Q&A and
discussion session that's Central Time
so you want to make sure that you check
your time zone for that on the 23rd at
12:00 p.m.
again another online event I'll be
hosting another one of my doctor Sadler
ask me anything a ma sessions so make
sure that if you want to get in on that
you ask your question right away because
they they tend to pile up and I can't
get to all of them then on the 28th at 6
p.m. here locally at the Shorewood
Public Library we have the MKE stoic
fellowship meeting we're gonna be
beginning a study of Epictetus
discourses and then the 30th at the
almost the very end of the month at 2:00
p.m. I will be having my philosophy chat
session for my patreon supporters the
other thing that I should mention if
you're here locally in the Milwaukee
area that you might want to check out
and that I'm definitely going to be at
is at the end of the month there is a
Aristotle and the Aristotelian tradition
conference hosted at Marquette
University which is just down the road
from from here where I'm based so I will
be there enjoying a lot of great papers
and discussion I won't be presenting but
I will be talking with a lot of the
participants and perhaps even
interviewing some of them now it's time
to talk about the podcast so for years
people have been saying can you turn
your videos into mp3s that we can
download and listen to anywhere and I've
always said well that's a lot of work
and so I decided to put it as one of my
patreon goals once I reached a certain
level of support on patreon which I
reached at the end of this last month
thanks to the generosity of my
supporters it's now feasible for me to
start can
hurting those videos into mp3s and
uploading them and that's exactly what
I've done you can find the link to that
I've hosted it in SoundCloud you can
find the link to that below and I
started with Plato I'd actually ran a
poll to see who people were most
interested in getting the podcast from
at first and and Plato is was up in the
top so or some other classic
philosophers and so are some
existentialist thinkers so that's that's
the plan for right now I'm not going to
be doing transcripts of them right away
that's going to be at a higher level of
patreon support and I've also you know
set at a significantly higher level I
will begin producing original podcast
rather than just taking video stuff and
turning those into episodes but that
that's for further down the line what
else you know I'm gonna continue doing
some writing this month in in all of my
blogs I also created a new blog just for
the podcast where you can find out
what's what's coming out if you want to
get a lot of you know philosophical
counseling tutorial and consulting work
this month coming up as well my schedule
is pretty full but if you're interested
in tutorials or philosophical counseling
you can email me directly at reason IO
or Greg at reason IO comm or just go to
the reason IO site and check those
services out the other thing that I'm
going to be doing and spending a lot of
time on this month is class preparation
I've been asked to teach two classes at
Marquette University in the fall two
different classes as it turns out one is
you know sort of the revised intro level
class and the other is a business ethics
class and I'm also going to be teaching
for the Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design a class specifically on
philosophy of human nature set up for
arts and design students so I got to do
a lot of thinking about exactly which
texts and thinkers and how to do
assignments and all the other
mystics involved with that so that's
gonna be something I'm gonna try to
knock out this this coming month what
else is there to talk about well my kids
are gonna be here for a week this month
so it was a weekend last month and now
it's gonna be a week and we're gonna
spend some great time together I'm still
doing my you know workouts
feeling great effects from from that but
I'll also be doing a lot of video work
I'm hoping to get my my quota of six
half-hour hagel videos done and maybe
even sooner than later this month
a lot of Heidegger's stuff yet to
release and the Play Doh stuff that I
produced and released ahead of time to
my patreon supporters that still has to
be released I've got some Q&A videos
lined up and I've got an interview that
I'm hoping all released tomorrow with a
good friend and colleague here in the
area and then the event videos you can
expect to see them and I'm gonna be
doing more book reviews I've gotten a
little bit behind and the books are
really piling up as people keep sending
them in to me so I think I need to start
cranking those out maybe do one each
week for the time being so you can
expect to see an uptick in those so
that's everything going on this month I
hope that you have a great month and
check out the podcast and and if you can
make it to any of the online events I
hope to see you there
you